ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ตอนดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่า
ครูหญิงมีปากกาเปิดประกาแล้วใช่ไหมคะผู้
ชายค่ะ
แล้วก็ยกกระดานขึ้นมาจ่ายยกกระดานขึ้นมา
ค่ะแล้วก็มีปากการเขียนนะคะเขียน
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะตี 5 ปีพศ.
2565 ค่ะผู้หญิงครัวราะอะไร
หัวเราะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋มาปีพตเขาไหร่คะคุยก็
เขา
มีข้อศ.เท่าไหร่คะมีข้อ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 ราคาวันนี้วันอาทิตย์เมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 9
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์เมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะไม่มีนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11 ค่ะ
4  21 นะคะแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
เวลานาฬิกาไม่มี
กูเองกูเองว่านาฬิกาก่อนได้ไหมได้ค่ะนี่
ไงนาฬิกา
นาฬิกา
นาฬิกาน่าจะอยู่ที่อันนี้มือมือแขนข้อสอบ
ข้อมือนะคะตรงนี้ข้อมือนาฬิกาจะอยู่ที่
ข้อมือ
ครูเอกก็นาฬิกานาฬิกา
ไม่มีนาฬิกาที่ข้อมือค่ะตัวเองไม่ได้ใส่
นาฬิกา
เวลากี่โมง
เวลา
03:00 น
23 นาทีค่ะบ่าย 15:00 น 23 นดูนาฬิกาก็
ผู้หญิงไม่ต้องดูข้อมือข้อมือครูเอ๋ไม่มี
นาฬิกานะคะภายค่ะ
ครูหญิงอะไรคะครูเอ๋สักครู่นะคะคุณของก้ม
ลงไปหยิบ
หยิบอะไรคะแปลงลบกระดานค่ะผู้หญิงสมาลบ
กระดานคุยอิ๋งลบแล้วมันมีฝุ่นมั้ยพูด
มีค่ะ
จาม
ตามค่ะงามนะคะค่ะ
นักเรียนของเรากี่คนคะนักเรียนของเรา 1  2
3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11
11 คนค่ะ 11 คนนะคะก็รู้หญิงวันนี้วัน
นี้วันนี้ครูเอ๋มีคำถาม
พี่เอมีคำถามได้มีคำถามถามครูหญิงก่อนอ่า
ถามอะไรคะครูหนีถามครูหญิงแล้วก็เดี๋ยว
ถามตัวเองอ๋อ
ดายเรียนด้วยครูผู้หญิงคะผู้หญิงเป็นคน
ไทยใช่ไหมคะใช้ค่ะครูหญิงเป็นคนไทยอยู่
ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงวาดประเทศ
ไทยได้ไหมคะเล็กๆเป็นธรรมอย่างยิ่งว่าสวย
นะคะครูเอ๋โอ๊ยใหญ่ไปไหมคะใหญ่ไปหรอคะ
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะวาดประเทศอื่นยังไงอ้า
ประเทศไทยสวยแล้วอ่ะเอาเล็กๆตัวเล็กๆเน็ต
ทรูเอบอกว่าวาดประเทศไทยเล็กๆๆตรงกลางได้
ไหมคะตรงกลางกระดานคุย
ใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆ
ถึงว่าประเทศไทยเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงต้องวาด
ญี่ปุ่นว่าจีนวาดไทเปวาดเกาหลีวาดอเมริกา
ก็เลยต้องวาดไทยเล็กๆแต่ต้องวาดตรงกลาง
ไม่รู้เป็นไทยไว้คะประมาณนี้นะคะประเทศ
ไทยโอเคโอเคป่ะ
โอเค
ประเทศไทยผู้หญิงเลยญี่ปุ่นอยู่ตรงไหนคะ
คนอยู่ที่นี่ค่ะญี่ปุ่นอะไรคะเพราะใจดู
อ่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงญี่ปุ่นอยู่ทางโน้นอีก
ทางนึงอ้าวหรอขอโทษค่ะขอขอบคุณทาดาชิค่ะ
ครูหญิงวัดทิศทาง
โอเคโอเคคู๋วาดให้ดีไหม
ญี่ปุ่นเป็นยังไงอ้ะกฎมีกลมๆข้างบนแล้วก็
อื้อลงพยามคะ
xxx ข้างนึงอ่ะผู้หญิง
โค้งอีกของหน่าแล้วก็มีข้างล่าง
1  2 เหรอคะโอเคๆญี่ปุ่น
ขอโทษคนญี่ปุ่นนะคะไม่เหมือนโอเคนะแปลก
คนที่พบว่าแอร์ญี่ปุ่นมีฮอกไกโดชิวชิว Con
ชิวอะไรนะก็ไก่โด
โอเคนะว่า you  see  Voice งงหนูไม่เป็น
ไรค่ะญี่ปุ่น OK
อ๋อเคเคครูหญิงนะอยู่ประเทศไทยผู้หญิงเคย
ไปนะไปอ่ะไปวัดไปเลยนะไป
ๆไปๆญี่ปุ่นไหมคะมั้ยเทยค่ะผู้หญิงเคยไป
ที่ไหนคะครูหญิงเคยไป
อเมริกา
อเมริกาอเมริกาเล็กๆเนาะ
ออกไกลนะคะกะอันนี้ใกล้ไกล
เอาเอามาลิกาไกล
จากประเทศไทยก็เลยเล็กๆคุยอีกเลย
ไปทำอะไรคะ
ไปอเมริกาไปเที่ยวค่ะไปดูอ๋ออ๋อไปดู
อเมริกา
จะไปถ่ายรูปแล้วคู่หญิงนอนที่ไหนคะ
นอนโรงแรมค่ะนอนโรงแรมนะคะโรงแรมมีดาวผู้
หญิงไปคนเดียวหรอคะ
ไปสองคนไปกับเพื่อนค่ะ
แมง 2  2 คนครนะคะโอเคอ่า
ยืนคู๋สงสัยค่าครูหญิงต้องไปเอาเมริกาภาพ
เคลื่อนคนไทยคนเอานาฬิกา
คนอเมริกา
และผู้หญิงไปบ้านบ้านเพื่อนมั้ยใช่ๆค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไปนอนโรงแรมด้วยไปบ้าน
บ้านคนอเมริกาก็ดีแล้วครูหญิงต้องมีของ
ฝาก
มีไหม
[เพลง]
กริ๊งมะยีอะไรจากประเทศไทยไปฝากคนอเมริกา
เลย
ไม่มี
ไอ้ผู้หญิง
รูแย้ครูหญิงไม่รู้
ไม่รู้
ผู้หญิงต้องมีของฝาก
แล้วกูหญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยคู๋แต่งงาน
แล้วหน้า
Thank  You เหล้ามีเป็น
มิสเตอร์ Japan เป็นคนญี่ปุ่นที่ไหนคะ
เพราะใจดู
ไม่ใช่ฮอกไกโดๆ
ถ้าโตอะที่นี่นะ
เวลาครูเอ๋ไปก็จะมีของฝากเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ให้
ดูนะให้ได้ๆเดี๋ยวสักครู่ค่ะ
มาแล้วฆ่าผู้หญิงกูเอมมี่อะไรในมือ
เหนื่อยเหรอคะยิ่งไปหยิบของฝากค่ะ
ยิ้มเอ๋
ถ้าหลุดแล้วโอเคหลุดแล้วเปิดได้ค่ะ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋มีอะไรเป็นของฝากอาจ
ให้คุณพ่อสามี
มันหลุดแล้วเนาะ
โอเคไม่เปิดดีกว่าค่ะได้ๆนี่แหละ
ชามเหรอใครกู a ให้ค่ะชาม
เห็นไม่ฝนไม่มี
ญี่ปุ่นมีชาม
แต่ว่าอันเนี้ย Time ถ่ายโฮ้โฮ้ครูเองผู้
หญิงถ้วยเอาถ้วยเอาเล็กผู้หญิงคิดใหญ่ๆ
วิ่งมึงกูแอร์เก่งผู้หญิงกินข้าวได้เลย
นั้นใจรนุช
เป็นถ้วยถ้าชามจากขนาดนี้เออค่ะตามไป
ถ้วยที่ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมถ้ามีโอ
มีช้าง
ช้างช้างเห็นแล้วนักเรียนเรียนเห็นช้าง
ไหมนี่เห็นๆเห็นแล้วผู้หญิงแกไหมเหมือน
กันสางอันนี้สวยกว่า
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ช้างสีฟ้า
อันนี้คือสีเขียวใช่มั้ยเขียวสีเขียวฮ่วย
สีเขียวนายทั่วไปอันนี้ชื่อคนไทยพูดศิลา
ดล
งอประเทศญี่ปุ่นมีถ้วยศิลาดลไหมคะ R
อาทิตย์ว่ามีแต่แพงอ๋อแต่เป็นของประเทศ
ไทยมายนะคะศิลาดลสีสีเขียวนะคะหน้าบางที
นักเรียนพูดเวลาฎอนออกเหมือนกัน
ตั้งเวลาดอนแต่คนไทยน่ะศิลาดลคนไทยบางคน
ก็พูดเซลาดอนบางคนก็พูดศิลาดลหมู is ศิลา
ดลให้คุณพ่อหนูเมื่อก่อนมีถ้วยกาแฟ
กาแฟศิลาดล
มีนะคะถ้วยกาแฟ
ศิลาดลอันนี้เป็นถ้วยใส่ซุปใส่
ศิลาดลนะคะน้องซื้อไปฝาก
มีของฝากหนูหนูปลุก
วงครูหญิงไม่รู้
อันนี้ฝากครูเอ๋ให้รู้เหรอถ้าครูหญิงคิด
ไปเองอยู่ในอเมริกา is
แล้วก้อไปบ้านคนอเมริกาครูหญิงซื้ออะไร
เป็นของฝากจากประเทศไทยดีคะอะไรดีนะ
เดี๋ยวกูเอาให้ดูแล้วผู้หญิงคิดผู้หญิง
ชอบอร่อยได้ค่ะชุดผู้หญิงจะได้แบบ
มีไอเดียอ้าโอเคค่ะผู้หญิงไหม
กำลังฮิตกำลังมายังไม่เห็นค่ะยังไม่เห็น
ล่ะคะมายังมาแล้วขาดแต่เดี๋ยวผัวคุยอิง
ขยายครูใหญ่ๆก่อ
1 ครูหญิง
งั้นแล้วค่ะ
อะไรบ้างคะครูเอ๋เดี๋ยวนะคะได้ค่ะ
อันที่ 1 คุยเช็คสีแดงเขียนนะอ่ะค่ะครู
เอ๋เอชอบสีแดงไม่ได้ Top
นี้ค่ะอันที่ 1 ผู้หญิงผู้อันที่ 1 อะไร
คะครูเอ๋หมอนอิง
หมอ
รอสักครู่ครูเอ๋กำลังเดินไปหาหมอ
ครูเอ๋มีมีหมอนอิงงูยักษ์ดีมากค่ะครู
ใหญ่วะ
ใหญ่เหมอนิงทำอะไรหมอนอิงเอาไว้ว่างแล้ว
ก็
เรา
ได้ขอโทษนะคะบางทีก็เอาไว้แล้วก็ขาวางขา
ขาค่ะไม่ไม่ดีใช่ไหมค่ะขึ้นมาขาสูงๆอ๋อ
อันนี้ครูเอ๋คะแล้วก็ตัวแล้วก็ขาง่าย
ขอวางขาหน้าๆเออบ้านที่พูดหมอนอิงบ้านผัก
พูดหมอนสามเหลี่ยมหรือ
ทำให้สอนสามเหลี่ยมเหลี่ยมที่ 1
เตรียมที่ 2
เหลี่ยมที่สามค่ะอ๋ออ๋อหมอนสามเหลี่ยมใน
ค่ะเอาเป็นอันนี้สามเหลี่ยมค่ะซื้อไปฝาก
คนอเมริกาคนญี่ปุ่นได้คนที่ปุ่นชอบ
อเมริกาชอบไหมอ่ะ
ไม่รู้นักเรียนอเมริกาคอมเม้นนะข้างล่าง
ยี่ห้อมั๊ยค่ะชายญี่ปุ่นชอบค่ะโอ้โห
คนไทยถ้าชอบเหมือนกัน
อย่างที่สองอย่างที่สองอะไรคะครูเอ๋อัน
ไหนอย่างที่สองยาหม่องยาหม่องคืออะไรอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไหนยาหม่องคู๋มียาหม่องค่ะเวลาที่
ที่ยุงรู้จักยุงไหมคะค่ะ
ยุง
อยู่เนี่ยบินมางู
แล้วก็เกาะค่ะก็ปากอ้ะ
กิน
กินเลือดเราใช่ไหมคะอันนี้อะ
น่าอยู่ก็ตอบก็ที่นี่มีเส้นเลือดมีสีแดง
ยุงก็กินแล้วก็
มี
สีแดงๆ
ฮ่ายุงก็ตัวใหญ่ขึ้นค่าแล้วยุงก็ไปอ้าว
แล้วแขนเป็นยังไงท่านค่ะ
คันแล้วทำยังไงเก่าค่ะเก่า
เก่าๆมากๆไม่เจ็บเหมือนกัน
เกาแล้ว
ยังคัน
ทำยังไงอย่ามองค่ะแล้วใช้ยังไงคะยาเมาก็
เปิดนะครับเปิดเอามือเนี่ยมือมือเห็นไหม
ฮะเห็นค่ะจับมือจับฝานะคะจับฝายาหม่อง
แล้วก็กูเอ๋อันนี้กะคึดจะได้เห็นก็คือ
เนี้ยจับฝายาหม่องนะคะเราก็หมุนหมุนหมุน
หมุน 1 ขึ้นค่ะแล้วว่างๆว่ะค่ะแล้วทำยัง
ไงต่อนิ้ว
ปลายยาหม่อง
แล้วทำยังไงต่อคะห่า
เอ้ายุงกัดที่นี่ก็ถ้าที่นี่
[เพลง]
จะอันนี้ดีมากนะเวลา
ปวดหัว
ปวดหัวใช้ยาหม่องได้ฟังภาษาไทยไม่เข้าใจ
ปวดหัวยาหม่อง
ค่าที่อันนี้เรียกอะไรคะขมับนะ
ทาขมับอ่ะแล้วก็แบบไม่ปวดหัวตายหรือๆถ้า
ง่วงนอน
ยาหม่องทาที่ไหนง่วงนอนค่าที่ตา
เห็นเด็กๆถ้าตาลุกตื่นห้องโอเคน่าจะเรียน
เนี่ยฟังภาษาไทยปวดหัวๆง่วงนอนทายาหม่อง
ที่ขมับทาที่ตาที่นี่นะไม่ใช่ข้างในนะ
เออไม่ชอบไม่ต้องถ่านะคะ
หรือนักเรียนเวียนหัว
แบบ
ก็
ไม่ไม่ทา
ดมถ้าที่นี่ก็ได้เราถูกดมนะดี
หรือบัญชีนักเรียนโอ๊ยขา
ขาหาเป็นอะไร
[เพลง]
ปวดขา
ใช้ยังไงเอายาหม่องจำเอาเอา
นิ้วป้ายยาหม่องเราทามะคาที่ขาแล้วก็รู้
อ่ะนวดโห
กู
ราคาดีนะฮะยาหม่องดีค่ะโอโห้โอเคไหมคุณ
หญิงโอเคอันนี้ดีค่ะอันนี้ชอบชอบๆอย่าบอก
แล้วนะมีต่อไปมีอีกใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ใช่ค่ะ
ถามอันที่ 3 โถอะไรคะครูเอ๋อย่าอย่าดม
มรรคญาณอารมณ์ใช้ยังไงครูเอ๋ไม่มียาดม
เป็นอันนี้แล้วก็หมุนเปิดแล้วก็
อันนี้จมูกแล้วก็ 3 จมดมอีกด้านหนึ่งก็
เปิดเปิดแล้วก็บีบบีบแล้วค่ะทาขมับผ่าน
เค้าขอคล้ายๆยาหม่องแต่ฤทธิ์เนาะเล็กๆอ่ะ
อย่าใส่ๆนะคะแล้วมีอีกไหมคะของฝากจาก
ประเทศไทยมีอีกค่ะ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋
กางเกง
กางเกงอะไรอ่ะมีอันเนี่ยที่ 4 นะคะสีฟ้า 4
กางเกงมวยไทย
มวยไทยประเทศไทยให้
เธอ
เหนื่อยไหมคะมวยไทย
มวยไทยประเทศไทยก็ต้องมีกางเกงมวยเอ้า
แล้วบางคนชอบ
ไปแต่กางเกงมวยไทยแล้วกางเกงอีกตัว
อะไรคะอันที่ห้านะคะคะของของฝากแล้วก็บอก
ของฝากน้อของฝากชิ้นที่ถ้า n ที่ 5
กางเกงถามทาง
อีกแล้วก็ประเทศไทยประเทศท้างโห
หา
กางเกงช้างค่ะ
อันนี้
คิดว่าเวลาใส่สบายๆคือ
แล้วก็ครูเอ๋บอกช้างทั่วประเทศไทยๆก็มีคน
ชอบกางเกงมวยกางเกงช้าง
กางเกงมวยเป็นของฝากซื้อกางเกงช้างเป็น
ของฝากนะคะค่ะยังไม่หมดผู้หญิงมีอีก Being
อีกเหรอคะของฝากชิ้นต่อไปอะไรคะ
ๆค้าง
ปลอกหมอนโหอะไรคะปลอกหมอนโอเค
หมอน
หมอนนะคะแล้วอันเนี้ยหมอนค่ะอันนี้เป็น
ปลอกหมอน
on หมอนะคะแปลว่าอันนี้เป็นปลอกหมอนอิง
หมอนที่วะอาซินข้างหลังแล้วก็นั่งอ๋อ
จะเป็นปลอกหมอนช้างค่ะหนูขา
ช้าๆๆๆความผู้หญิงอะไรคะครูเองชอบไหม
ค้างเหรอคะ
ค่ะไม่ชอบค่ะครูเอ๋ก็ไม่มีปลอกหมอนช้าง
ที่บ้านไม่มีครูเอกชอบแบบนี้
ปลอกหมอนไม่มีอะไรค่ะครูหญิงชอบเหมือนครู
เอ๋ค่ะไว้มีอะไรนะคะเอาแต่
นักเรียนไว้ใช่คนไทยไง
นักเรียนนักเรียนกับครู AOA ไปช้อปปิ้ง
ด้วยกันคุยถามซื้ออะไรค่ะซื้อ
ปลอกหมอนหมอช้าง
on นักเรียนซื้อไปฝาก
นาย
สีปล่องของฝากซื้อกางเกงมวยไทยนี่ซื้อ
กางเกงช้างได้กางเกงช้างกางเกงมวยไทยอัน
นี้
อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
สักครู่นะค่ะได้ค่ะตัวเอง
กางเกงมวยไทยกางเกงช้างค่ะแล้วก็ปลอกหมอน
ช้างบอกหมอนช้างนะคะ
มีอีกค่ะคือผู้หญิงไม่หมดล่ะคะมีของฝาก
อะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋อันนี้อาทิตย์คนญี่ปุ่น
ชอบ
งู
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ข้าวไรซ์เบอรี่
โอ๊ยสีใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋สีอะไรสีดำสีน้ํา
ผึ้งคนไทยบอกสีดำสีดำสีดำแบบเนี้ยจริงๆสี
สีม่วงไหมครับครูเอ๋ๆสี The นะ
จะคุยหาก่อน
สีเนื้อ
สีแบบเนี้ยสีม่วง
สีม่วงกับสีแดงเนาะค่ะสีม่วงสีแดงด้วยกัน
อะนั่งง้อแต่ผสม
ให้ดูเป็นสีม่วงสีดูแล้วก็ดำสีดำเอาสี
ม่วงกับสีแดงด้วยกันก็สีดำ
แรงดำ
วันนี้คนญี่ปุ่นชอบเป็นของฝากคนโป้
ญี่ปุ่นชอบ
งายคนอเมริกาคนอังกฤษคนอินเดียคนอะไรหวาน
ได้หวันชอบมั้ยครูเอ๋ไม่รู้นะคะคนประเทศ
นักเรียนพ่อคอมเมนท์ได้นะคะมีอีกมีอีกมี
ของฝากอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
เซ็นเซ็นงั้น
อะไรคะเป็นกลมกลมๆไข่มุก
สีมุกมาจากไหนอ่ะครูเอ๋ครูเก็บอ๋อ
ยิ่งนักเรียนรู้จักภูเก็ต
คิดว่านักเรียนรู้จักนะถูกเก็บ
ภูเก็ตอ่ะคุยว่าประเทศไทยให้นอกได้ค่ะ
ภูเก็ตอยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะ
ก็คือ
เหมือนไหมประเทศไทยเผื่อนมากกว่าครูหญิง
ว่านภูเก็ตอยู่ที่นี่สมุยอยู่ที่ภูเก็ต
ภูเก็ตมีเกาะค่ะเกาะเล็กๆมีฟาร์ม
ฟาร์มไข่มุกโอ๊ยถ้าครูผู้หญิงไปภูเก็ต
ซื้อไข่มุกได้ซื้อได้ค่ะเป็นของฝาก
แต่
แตงอะไรคะครูเอ๋แห่งนก
ครูเอรู้ไหม
กี่บาทไม่รู้แต่คิดนะแพงไข่ให้ใช่แรงราคะ
อ่ะกางเกงโอเคหากการกางเกงกางเกงไม่แพง
ต่อไปแผง
199 บาทโอเคกางเกงมวยแพงระแหงชาอา
ยาหม่องไม่แพง
ยาดมเบอร์ 3 แพงไหมคะถูก
หมอลาดโอเค 3  400
400 บาท 400 บาท
โอเคน้องโอเค
ยาดมเท่าไหร่อ่ะ
สิบห้าบาทไหมคะยี่สิบยี่สิบมาเนาะประมาณ
เนาะรูหญิงครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่รู้ค่ะยาหม่องก็
อ่ะห้าสิบถึงสองร้อยบาท
อันนี้ก็ไม่แพงไม่แพงนี้นะคะค่ะข้าว
ไรซ์เบอรี่ก็ประมาณกี่บาทคะ
200 บาทได้ไหม 200 บาทไม่แพงไปแพงค่ะ
หมอนก็ประมาณปลอกหมอนช้างประมาณ
350 บาทก็โอเคไม่แพงไม่แพง
มุกไข่มุกภูเก็ตด้วย
คิดว่าแพงนะชายค่ะแพงกับกูเองไม่รู้เท่า
ไหร่หนึ่งเดี๋ยวนะอะไม่เอาอันเนี้ย
โห้คันใช่ไหมมี
000 เนี่ย 3 ตัวอาจจะ 1,000  2,000
3,000  4,000
ก็แล้วแต่เกรดอะไรนะฮะก็ไม่มีหนึ่งหมด
เหรอ 1  m  1  m
1  M  100  100 บาทไม่มีนะคะผู้หญิงไม่
มีไม่มีไม่มีไม่มีก็
มุกก็จะแพงแพงนิดหน่อยฮ่าฮ่าๆน้องเล่นของ
ฝากได้ราคา
ของฟรีดีคู่หญิงชอบอะไร
ผู้หญิงชอบ
เบอร์ 5 ค่ะของฝากอีกเหรอ 5 กางเกงช้าง
กางเกงช้างไม่แพงแล้วก็สวยอะแล้วก็ครู
หญิงชอบของฝากเบอร์ 1
หมอนอิงหมอนเองก็เล็กๆก็มีเล็กๆคิดว่า
สบาย
We  Are ราคา
จริงๆของฝากยังมีอีกมากๆนะครูหญิงใจแม่
ครูหญิงอะไรคะผู้หญิงอยากรู้ไหมอยากรู้
อะไร
เวลาคุยอิ๋งไปอเมริกาไปญี่ปุ่นไปเกาหลี
ไปไต้หวัน
ไปที่อื่นซื้ออะไรเป็นของฝากมีของ
กระเป๋า
ทองอันนี้จากของฝากจากประเทศอะไรคะจาก
ประเทศต่องต้อง
ไปต้องกล้าแล้วก็ซื้อกระเป๋ามาฝาก
ให้นะฮะเป็นกระเป๋าจากต้องจะนี่หาครูเอ๋
ของฝากจากอาเมริกาอะไรคะ
ฤทธิ์ค่ะลิฟท์ค่ะครูเอ
ประเทศไทยก็มีไอ้มีอันนี้เป็นลิปที่เป็น
สไปรท์
โคคาโคล่าแฟนต้าค่ะ
แล้วก็ไม่แพงๆหามีอะไรอีก
กู a หาของฝาก
เคหา
แต่ว่ากดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะได้ใช่นักเรียน
คอมเม้นบอกได้เนาะไปสวีเดนมีอะไรเป็นของ
ฝากไปญี่ปุ่นอะไรเป็นของฝากแต่คู๋รู้ว่า
ต้องกล้ามีอันนี้มีกี่ 2
ขอไรไหมคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงกูเอกรู้จัก
ญี่ปุ่นนิดนึงมีของฝากกู a ให้ดูของฝาก
จากญี่ปุ่น
ขอให้แบตๆๆ
อะไรคะมีขนมโต๊ะ
นำชื่ออะไรอ่ะพี่เอ๋คู๋ไม่รู้ชื่อฮ่าๆ
กูเองไม่รู้ชื่อโอเคไม่รักคนญี่ปุ่นมาก็
จะซื้อขนมมาฝากคนไทยค่ะอันนี้อะไรนะผู้
หญิงอันนี้เป็นโชคดีเสื้อไหมกูเอ๋เครื่อง
รางเรื่องราง
สีแดงดีกว่าอันนี้เป็นค่ะเรื่องลางนะคะ
ทั้งแล้วก็พวงกุญแจ
หงอเวลามีกุญแจแล้วก็ให้ก็แล้วอันนึงอะไร
คะของฝากที่เป็นลิงเอออันนี้เขาบอกสำหรับ
โชว์มี
อาคมไทยคลิปพวงกุญแจ
ญี่ปุ่นคิดเหมือน
เครื่องรางเอาเป็นลิง
ลิงค์ข้างบนปิดหู
ใช่มั้ยตัวที่ 1 ติดหูวันที่ 2 ติดต่อต
แล้วตัวที่ 3 ปิดตาอ๋ออ่านะคะนิเครื่อง
รางสำหรับโชคดีหายอ่าของ
โอ้ยนี่รู้แล้วไงอ่ะไปญี่ปุ่นซื้ออะไร
เป็นของฝากญี่ปุ่นก็มีมากๆเนาะค่ะชายมาด
นักเรียนก็คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะว่ามินอะไร
จ๊ะครูหญิงไปญี่ปุ่นไปอเมริกาซื้ออะไร
ดีเจถามคอมเม้นท์นักเรียนชอบนักเรียนนะ
ชอบของฝากอะไรของประเทศไทยหรอคะจากประเทศ
ไทยจ๋าที่ประเทศไทยค่ะคอมเม้นท์ได้มี 2  2
คำถามนะคะคำถามที่ 1 ครูหญิงไปซื้ออะไร
เป็นของฝากค่ะกับสองนักเรียนมาไทย
ชอบซื้ออะไรเป็นของฝาก
2 นะ comment ได้ภาษาโอเคคลิปนี้ครูหมด
เวลา
หมดเวลาแล้วไปแล้วค่ะค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย